Benjamin 4 ans regarde les aventures de
la Pat' patrouille tous les matins et il
connaît par cœur le nom de ces héros
sur la pat'patrouille depuis quitte ou
si c'est l'émission qui aime le plus
[Musique]
émission culte la pat'patrouille a vu le
jour en 2013 cette série canadienne met
en scène les aventures du jeune rider et
de tes amis canin dans les célèbres et
Marcus après la télévision voici
maintenant pas de patrouille le film qui
se déroule à aventure ville une ville en
danger
et
le chien préféré mon venir
sauver les citoyens de tous les dangers
qui ont été mis sur la route par le
maire de d'Inger
un autre
groupe sur place
quand on
va faire ça
pour animer c'est roi de la débrouille
certains plein on essaie c'était
plusieurs mois travaille dans la fin de
l'explosion initiale
et d'avoir
les enfants donc ça a été de faire une
explosion qui est grandiose mais en même
temps qui est pas effrayante
grâce à des projets comme pat'patrouille
le film le secteur de l'animation et en
croissance à Montréal et pour notre
projet animation à tout au défi à
relever cherche un micro près de 400
personnes qui pourrait nous rejoindre au
cours des prochains mois
pat'patrouille quel est le problème en
attendant de voir le film la mère de
Benjamin le plus empêcher d'acheter des
pâtes de la pat'patrouille
aussi la pat'patrouille toute la toutes
les affaires qu'on voit les fichiers de
la pat'patrouille mais on les achète pas
ce qu'on veut faire plaisir et pour lui
faire plaisir Benjamin ira voir Pat
patrouille le film de sa sortie cette
fin de semaine
[Musique]